how is she gonna catch your girlfriend
how you doing
[Music]
today's episode of answer the internet
is brought to you by Roman stick around
to the very end for more details
I'm Tommy Pope and this is Chris
O'Connor and welcome
to answer the interview would you rather
have to watch a sex tape of your parents
every day for the rest of your life or
watch every game your sports team plays
and they lose every time I kind of want
to see what my mom's up to
in a you want to see what she's up to
every day
oh it's everything I'm sorry seeing my
parents have sex once wouldn't bother me
because I can't I can't see it being
good you want to watch your parents have
bad sexy what's better what's worse
that's fun it's like watching a comic
bomb you know what I mean if I see my
dad be bad in bed dude he couldn't say
[ __ ] to me the rest of his life what are
you gonna tell me they got the long
house I saw you blow a load early that's
interesting how long are they [ __ ]
for
because I'd rather watch my dad [ __ ] bad
for like two minutes this is and watch
like a three or four hour game 100 that
you know yeah you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah you're gonna lose that's just
that that's just an efficiency thing
yeah yeah yeah would you rather be an
extremely good looking paralyzed person
so me and a chair or a hidey is fully
functioning person
throw a leg out of my skull if I can if
I could jog a six minute mile I don't
know chicks don't chicks tend not to
[ __ ] good joggers I think you'd want
like a yeah I don't know Chris we were
doing like an actual talent which
activity takes more physical fitness
golf or porn porn easily shut up
golf a million times over porn you could
beat off 30 seconds
yeah Jesus Christ oh golf
time's over again you just want to say
this because you think you're good at
golf Adriana chechik broke 10 out of 10
times [ __ ] no golfers ever broke
their neck it's just a [ __ ] that jumped
into the ball pit and broke herself
before that's the second time
yeah yeah
yeah sorry you're made of glass gee but
golf is much harder than getting tanked
in the ass I think so would you rather
[ __ ] your dream girl from high school or
go back in time and change your worst
childhood Sports loss to a win I hate to
be mean they dream girl in high school
you see now looks like a bag of hot dogs
you grow up and you're like oh [ __ ] yeah
hold on can we start no no I [ __ ] my
dream girl in high school damn oh yeah
hold on if you're in high school and
you're you're actually achieving this
goal that's not really your dream girl
that's just attainable girl we're
talking someone that you couldn't
possibly touch if she had sex with her
she's not your dream girl this girl in
school you [ __ ] her you did
yeah yeah damn Chris off topic that's
that's pretty rare that's pretty [ __ ]
right yeah like it's not all good news
some bad things happened in between yeah
I'd change a loss Archbishop Ryan yeah
Monsignor Bonner we were undefeated we
were favorites to win the Catholic
League Championship I hit a ball in the
first pitch wow over the fence huh
exhausted from
it
please
please when the next time we do this
could it be like 9 A.M 8 30. first of
all
starts thank you
I know Chris I just want to get you guys
I want to get your honey air before the
workout just once
dream girl all of a sudden he's got
[ __ ] he's got he's got rules all of a
sudden
I gotta get out of here would you rather
be able to [ __ ] any girl you wanted or
teleport anywhere in the world anywhere
in the world yeah that's you can
teleport anywhere in the world you're
[ __ ] anyone in the world yeah that's
a good point too you could literally
[ __ ] anybody in a hoodie like would you
rather have a billion dollars or [ __ ]
any Chick you want imagine this kid
falling in France in like the 40s
France in the 40s with these teeth yeah
oh my God you're so right yeah yeah
for ten thousand dollars would you spend
two days carrying around a human looking
Japanese robot yes that you had to
introduce to people as your girlfriend
yeah what a ten thousand dollars dude
yeah I agree with you I'm sorry
what kind of [ __ ] Rich [ __ ] this
wouldn't do this for 10 grand in two
days that's five grand a day to just
have fun for a little you can bother
people I honestly don't think I'm gonna
oh shut the [ __ ] what are you talking
about
dude you said you bought the jaw
strengthening thing to build out your
jaw because Instagram
all right well we don't think it's gonna
be [ __ ] on Instagram advertising you're
gonna get bot also you never had like a
box you never had like a difference yeah
dude you'll be the first one into the
breach yeah I'm so you don't stand a
chance I'm so upset with his behavior
right now
30 seconds
dude you're [ __ ] you're gonna come
home in your head you're like I hope my
[ __ ] hole three thousand is alert and
charged
yeah you're gonna have fun in the next
decade how much money would it take for
you not drink for a year
17 sex robots
working together I did a week and that's
pretty [ __ ] that was good and they
paid you and they paid you 450 yeah
still did it don't [ __ ] minimize my
ability you got paid to be sober yeah
and you took mushrooms halfway that's
the question that's the question you'd
have to put me in like Bali but then as
soon as I hit the sand I'd be [ __ ]
searching for cocktails behind your back
I was paying off every shady dude in the
corner yeah
yeah let me get a little I'd be snorting
Daiquiri I wouldn't give a [ __ ] how I
got in my system not a shot yeah suck my
dick with that what's that what's that
Paul Thomas Sanders robot or not dude
charged or not I'm [ __ ] an Uncharted
what's that would you take a million
dollars to be one of the pick the one of
the picket people for the West Baptist
Westboro Baptist Church during a fallen
soldier's funeral a million dollars I
would no joke I'd do that for five grand
I'm not even that's not a cool thing I
get it but like I'm a million dollars
dude a million dollars but you're not
allowed to drink I would undress my
father like slowly for a million dollars
I'd take it that weird Italian sausage
and this weird Buffon which I I'm sure
he's not [ __ ] Landscaping these days
guys 74. my father
I got a picture sorry was this about the
Westborough are you talking about
sucking your dad's dog where it's going
Chris just ride it dude Hit The Vape I
don't think we need the cards Dude well
I'm saying my dad so that's what it
costs sucking damn stick four or five
grand
as long as this bush is Fluffy as [ __ ]
damn
as long as it's fluff I want to hate but
he looks good
yeah 100 a million dollars what the [ __ ]
that's crazy it's crazy the offer was a
million you don't negotiate down a
million dollars is an insane amount of
money I would knock my mom oh that's
gotta get you know
yeah fuckberry kill my dad my dad my dad
sex to be able to
be able to I can't [ __ ] a robot I can
never insert into a fake woman
no no
dude yeah for sure for short Kings I'll
lay up with a smack in the backboard
yeah
by the strength
you're a sophomore in high school
slapping oh [ __ ] you hear the backboard
I got a would you rather for you would
you rather go bald early and have no
hair on your head or have a nice head of
hair because you went to Roman and you
got their shampoo and conditioner
medicated to keep the hair on your head
and you use their medication both over
the counter and prescription to keep
your hair growing I know my answer I'm
going to Roman go to row.co right now
it's a new URL row dot Co slash answer
and get 20 off your month of hair loss
treatment that's r o dot Co slash answer
for 20 off there were stats available
forever
if there was stats available for every
aspect of your life what one stat would
you want to see the fastest I've ever
run oh miles per hour I think it's over
22. dude this isn't the best guy yeah
yeah I can I can cruise I think LT we're
in 26. I think I was gonna say yeah I
can I'm four miles an hour slower than
him we talked about it oh Oh I thought
you meant Lawrence Taylor
dude I could fly back in the day you got
wheels but 20 miles an hour it's
ridiculous exactly why I want to know
the stat
this should be a patreon this is what we
got a race meet you in first yes skank
Fest they might be having yeah wow I bet
ourselves
that I have to take a [ __ ] in public if
I can't run faster than 20 miles an hour
and guess what that's why he hasn't run
I saw a fat guy running 18 the other day
Usain Bolt ran 27.33 yeah he said 22.
I'll tell you how many zones yeah I
think you're full
no it's seven miles an hour slower
I think in my fastest when I was like in
high school and then I could go 22. yeah
this is coming from but I think average
Usain Bolt 23. pigs run 11 miles per
hour I could crush a pig
how is she gonna catch your girlfriend
how you doing
world
you're starting to come around aren't
you no way no a roadrunner goes 20. you
think you're faster than a roadrunner I
think I could match a roadrunner this is
insane I know what the stat I want
before this you've ever hit a baseball
I want it to be two 215 feet 215. suck
my bird I hit a ball on top of uh it's
the only thing the only person that's
ever done it in my high school career
yeah the monastery center field where
all the where all the priests go sleepy
baby that was maybe like on top
dead straight and this kid was still it
was Little League Baseball yeah League
Baseball heaters too senior year I
blinked I swung so hard didn't feel a
goddamn thing right in the court you see
this is how you doing non-stop I got the
home plate got to the Dog House people
were like that ball didn't lay yeah I
know that's what I've heard about every
baseball he's ever hit I think he's
[ __ ] probably still has something
yeah
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out